[Música]
puesto
ya estamos casi al final quien de aquí
quiere ir a la fiesta luego yo soy el
último obstáculo que os queda
arratsaldean soy yo me el tram de
heredia os tengo que dar algo yo no soy
cómico soy programador voy a estar
contando chistes esto os da una idea de
cómo van de presupuesto
deben de ir de presupuesto como en el
funeral de mandela
que el intérprete del lenguaje de signos
había estudiado por correspondencia y se
ve que no tenía buzón
apologista del botón speak spanish
inés pérez freites
don't feel to bat desde el vídeo de
facebook the people we speak spanish de
momento y discover the money fan y en
inglés
está buscando
el tema de hoy el tema de hoy es ver el
mundo con los ojos de un niño
y representado por el juego pica el
juego donde un adulto se divierte
tapando y descubriendo la cara mientras
que un bebé que todavía no entiende cómo
funciona el universo pasa un momento de
terror existencial creyendo que la
persona de enfrente se ha evaporado
esto prepara al infante para sus años de
estudio quince años de terror
existencial a manos de sus compañeros y
profesores y lo prepara especialmente
para cuando termina sus estudios llega
al mundo real y vale para y ve para qué
vale todo lo que ha estudiado
estar aquí también me da la posibilidad
de compartir con vosotros el símbolo que
más me gusta este símbolo es un atlas es
el mapa más preciso que se puede dibujar
del mundo con solo 12 líneas explica un
montón de cosas cuando ves que el mundo
del café parece que ha alimentado todo
llega las cápsulas cuando te crees que
han hecho todo con los vídeos musicales
y llegan a amstel cuando me levanto una
mañana de buen humor y resuelvo tres
problemas que llevo atascado tres meses
con ellos este símbolo lo explica yo con
40 años no me iba mal con el software
pero mi vida no estaba completa un día
apareció por casualidad en un micrófono
abierta de monólogos cómicos y dije
soy cómico no soy cómico soy yo no soy
cómico me lancé descubrí que para estar
aquí no hace falta ser cómico basta con
decirles que eres cómico
te dan el micro y ahora que estoy en
escenario lo de que no soy cómico ya no
es mi problema ahora es vuestro problema
esta mañana ha empezado en el its to
vizarreta hablándonos del testing de
software yo me dedico al software de
manera profesional os puedo contar desde
dentro
una vez que has estado en el interior de
la fábrica de salchichas
la ensalada se vuelve de lo más
apetecible
yo sé cómo está hecho el software por
dentro
a mí el software me sorprende cuando
funciona
errar es humano pero para liarla del
todo hace falta un ordenador
después de estado silvia carretero con
nosotros ha compartido su aventura
egipcia
nos ha contado a qué huelen las momias
yo me he quedado con que huelen a lo
mismo que huelen las nubes
no me ha contestado la pregunta más
grande que tengo que seguro que la
compartís muchos que es donde están los
extraterrestres
construyeron las pirámides
y nos abre otra pregunta más que es a
qué huelen los extraterrestres
silvia contamos contigo para esto luego
hemos tenido a marco spring man que nos
ha hablado de la adaptación responsable
de la dieta vamos a ver una foto de
marko spring man antes de adaptar
responsablemente su dieta
habla de un tema que a mí me toca muy de
cerca yo tuve una novia vegana y luego
tuve un par de líderes que eran
vegetarianas hubo un momento que llegué
a pensar que había un problema con mi
salchicha
deduje que no era eso era un tema de
ética
hay gente que come solo cosas crudas
es decir piensan que es inmoral calentar
lo que comes de microondas ni hablamos
hay gente bulímica piensan que es
inmoral pagar lo que comes y luego están
los veganos es como vegetarianos pero
sin leche sin huevos y sin queso piensan
que es inmoral que te guste lo que comes
y yo no sabía qué hacer pero el otro día
estaba con un amigo en un bar lesbiano
vegano que si lo pensáis es el sitio más
anti salchichas que existe en el
universo y encontré mi camino y me echo
karni tarja no los karni tarja nos
pensamos que está que es inmoral comer
algo que no tuvo una oportunidad es
decir si lo que estás comiendo tiene
patas o aletas o alas tuvo una
oportunidad no supo usarla demasiado
bien pero la tuvo pero cuando veo el
brócoli
o sea que podría haber hecho el brócoli
para no estar en mi plato con lo cual
está mal entonces nosotros no comemos ni
frutas ni verduras no somos radicales
esos son los carne 'nos nosotros hacemos
una excepción para las patatas y otros
tubérculos si tuvieron una oportunidad
haber cavado más hondo y de esa manera
puedo comer mi chuletón con patatas
fritas
luego hemos tenido a carlos garbisu que
nos ha contado lo importante y lo
peligroso del mundo de las bacterias si
después de su charla alguien nos da
reparo saludar a la gente estrechando la
mano os presento una alternativa
de sexo ni hablamos
luego hemos tenido a cierva llegó a mí
me dieron la lista de ponentes para
hacer el resumen cómico y miré asier
vallejo como prólogo lo busqué en google
investigador de la caca digo vaya uno
fácil y luego ha venido nos ha contado
con entereza la vivencia y la
experiencia con su mujer de dar a luz a
un niño sin vida y como lo superaron si
alguien aquí sabe lo que es mirar al
mundo con los ojos de un niño y crear
una nueva vida donde es muy difícil son
ellos son la inspiración para todos
nosotros y si puedo decir algo es que
este niño en su corta vida gracias a
vuestra vivencia a vuestra experiencia y
gracias a esta charla ha cambiado el
mundo
luego hemos tenido a álvaro gonzález de
langarika nos ha resumido la interesante
historia de la canción de la paloma y de
su compositor sebastián iradier que
hasta hace poco para muchos de nosotros
era solo el primo sin calle de manuel
ahora ya tiene una plaza
a la vez con fama de mujeriego que se
hizo músico y se fue a recorrer el mundo
un clásico
un hombre con gran capacidad de conexión
está tan tan tan tan tan tan
me han dicho que está mal yo me siento
como el tercer primo de los ira dios no
tengo calle
no tengo plaza tengo un poco de música
no tengo musa me han dicho que está mal
si uso esto para ligar pero voy a
intentarlo
si llaman al número de teléfono en sus
pantallas les ofrecemos dos citas por el
precio de uno
me lancé en su granja o no ya veremos
cómo hacemos funcionar esto luego hemos
tenido la actuación de allison nivel dos
canciones dos temas magníficos where do
we go
y my house
es decir
ha sido una actuación en formato de
pregunta respuesta con final feliz
[Aplausos]
luego hemos visto el vídeo del pil blood
es un pálido azul que es una foto de
grupo que nos sacaron a todos hace unos
años la sacó el voyager 1 después de 3
13 años de viaje a 64 mil kilómetros por
hora a 6000 millones de kilómetros de
distancia es difícil visualizar esto yo
os voy a ayudar imaginaros que cogemos
toda la deuda mundial todo el dinero que
debemos 250 trillones de euros los
ponemos en monedas de un euro y los
ponemos en fila india bien toda esa
distancia es la distancia a la que
sacaron la foto 13 años a 64 mil
kilómetros por hora de euros que debemos
y no tenemos
azul pálido lo que me extraña es que no
salgamos blancos
pero la pregunta importante aquí es a
quién narices debemos todo este dinero
serán los extraterrestres por construir
las pirámides
en cualquier caso yo tengo una idea para
devolver esta deuda
simplemente hay que quemar tres o cuatro
veces más otredad lo tenemos resuelto
luego hemos tenido la charla de casandra
verá una charla muy valiosa muy
importante el contenido de esa charla es
muy importante un relato desde la
trinchera de la libertad de expresión y
yo espero que como sociedad decidamos
hacer el esfuerzo que es un esfuerzo de
escuchar cosas que no nos gusta oír si
no vamos a acabar todos teniendo que
hablar como r2 d2
y a veces las cosas que tienes que irte
las que no te gusta
puede ser el pasajero del vehículo
faltante espacial
sandro
con tu padre
luego hemos tenido ambiente rami lo que
nos ha contado su trabajo dando nombre a
la gran labor de muchas mujeres a lo
largo de la historia y a la labor de las
mujeres de los concejos de álava
es muy importante esto yo voy aa plagiar
le voy a darle nombre a algo importante
voy a darle nombre conocéis eso que
tienen en común los minnelli y los
mayores de 40 años es a ese atributo
inefable ese no querer adaptarse ese
creer que lo sabes todo más y mejor que
nadie eso no tiene nombre vamos a
llamarlo bicapa
y ahora que tiene nombre vamos a poder
utilizarlo para una de las labores más
importantes que es quejarnos tenístico
la siguiente charla que hemos tenido ha
sido dani villanueva otra charla muy
importante un mensaje muy muy importante
danny nos ha contado el mundo en el que
vivimos y como tal es el mundo que
vivimos entonces no lo sabemos hace una
charla muy cruda
para mí una charla muy cruda nos cuenta
y es todo lo que tenemos la civilización
la educación el bienestar son cosas de
un gran valor pero tienen otra cara todo
tiene otra cara ya lo sabía la sabiduría
china de hace cuatro mil años que
inventaron el símbolo del yin y el yang
y el nombre para contar exactamente esto
y a veces parece que nosotros lo hemos
olvidado unirnos algunos países nos
obligó a separarnos más de otros no es
gratis cuando se hace algo constructivo
siempre tiene algo destructivo y hay que
saberlo es importante mirarlo a veces no
tienes opción de decidir si se hace un
muro o no igual la opción que tienes es
decidir en qué lado del muro estás
y luego ha venido annelise borges
annelise nos ha traído un reflejo de lo
que pasa todos los días en el
mediterráneo
y
ha sido con su capacidad de comunicación
haz cosas y otras nos los sentimientos
de lo que pasa y esto es tremendamente
importante porque no sé si os habéis
dado cuenta los sentimientos son capaces
de mover mucha más energía que la razón
y esta labor es muy importante yo no sé
cómo abordar este problema pero espero
que a alguien al que le impactara en
estos sentimientos será capaz quizás
alguno de vosotros será capaz de ver un
ángulo nuevo desde el que podrá haber un
camino que nos lleve a un mundo donde
más gente se sienta acogida
lo hemos tenido la presentación de maría
salgado investigadora nos ha contado nos
ha contado su gran labor como
investigadores no son tan buenos como
periodistas nos ha dado una noticia
buena y una mala y no nos ha preguntado
en qué orden la queríamos la noticia
buena es que pueden curar el vih la
noticia mala es que sólo si tienes luz m
no ha pedido financiación pero seguro
que lo conseguirán
luego hemos tenido a audrey tan la
ministra digital de taiwán que está
consiguiendo cosas increíbles ha
conseguido poner de acuerdo a abrir los
taxistas en su país
audrey
can you take one bernanke
y no sabemos de dónde viene la energía
como la conseguido pero estoy seguro que
es de superar esos sentimientos tan
difíciles dentro de superar ese juicio
social y de hacer esa transición como
eso de pasar de ser programador a hacer
política
hemos tenido a tatiana khan sabelli que
nos ha contado otra historia como cogió
un momento muy difícil y lo convirtió en
un proyecto que ha mejorado la salud de
millones de personas
impresionante yo si hubiera estado el
mismo caso hubiera mandado a mi jefe al
garete me hubiera de vacaciones y haber
gastado el dinero que no tengo
soy autónomo o sea que tengo que pensar
el plano un poco mejor
y por último hemos tenido a josu martín
que nos ha contado otra enorme historia
de superación ha demostrado que si unes
mente y cuerpo no hay barreras y también
ha demostrado que un trasplante puede
curar el vih pero lo que no hay quien
cure es la vigorexia la adicción al
deporte
y álvaro nos ha dicho que hay una
canción que tiene más versiones
que la paloma
no voy a nombrarla
que no sea por una
no soy galar y su límite
no ahora
hago zuzendu hacking ave
comprar
sé que era malísimo
aunque era sus trayectorias
leño tics categoría espía
[Música]
real móvil
ah
cuando es hago la visita al aire
barnes comieron llegó
job a car bate
con dos hojas
ikusi de esa que al mirar y
sólo lo que tenía y todo
y que es bañan amor emateko
adrián es decir tengo mañana búscalo
bajo la falta usted ha era el codueño
uso a rapa total
anuncia quiero
nos da la gusta mirar buena
[Música]
cargas
ayuda el federal
para todos los ponentes y para todos los
ponentes
[Aplausos]